miley cyrus welcome to the show thank
you
how are you thank you so much i'm doing
really great i'm happy to be talking to
you even though we're
miles apart it seems like we're just
right there so this is this is working
out great
uh miley i i want to start by quoting
the first line of
uh your your song midnight sky it's it
and the line goes it's it's been a long
night and the mirror is telling me to go
home
what made you write those words all
right well you know it sounds much more
poetic to say the mirror tells me to go
home but the truth was i was actually
leaving
a club one night and i went to take a
photo and i realized
it was on selfie mode and i had been
sweating and dancing and like my
eyelashes are stuck to my face
and a mullet and sweat don't go great
together so it was like all stuck to my
head
everyone looked equally as horrible
because we had been dancing for like
four hours
um but it was really that it i you know
have you ever done that where you go to
take a photo and it's on selfie mode and
it's like under your chin and you look
crazy so that's what happened to me you
know when you get when you get the chin
and get older you don't do that anymore
i it was a total mistake i was scarred
but it did end up inspiring a song that
i'm proud of
talking about partying i mean most
people have been
have been drinking more during corona
but you've actually
you you've quit drinking i listen i try
not to become the face or spokes woman
for anything i think everybody
you know everybody adjusts to this
period differently and i think
um you know the best that we can do is
just stay connected as best as we can
because but but but is is this a part
for you of a
of a bigger change on a personal level i
think that i try to take every day
by day because i've made a lot of
statements that's again we started
talking about the lyrics
you know forever and ever no more this
idea that we have to commit to something
for forever which i think kind of sets
you up for disappointment
you're you're a kind of person that you
have you have these abilities and if you
don't use them
they they kind of turn against you i
think you said that
once what what yeah in what way do they
turn against you
i mean i have to really get worn out and
exhausted
to feel like i've gone through the
energy that i wake up with every morning
and so when i have too much of that
energy and i'm not
giving some of it away because by
creating music
even making films directing you're
giving a part of yourself away to
thousands and millions of people that
are gonna watch it
and so when i have too much of the
energy to hoard for myself
it can create not not great scenarios in
my life
and what kind of scenarios would that be
i don't like to sleep very much so
that's
that's definitely i i'm not someone that
likes to really rest my mom said when i
was a kid i would sleep with my eyes
open because i really wanted to not
sleep
that much and so for that sleep can be
challenging
that can be a little dangerous i know
that's the whole thing is you've gotta
you've gotta recharge and i think
part of it like with that is dreaming is
exercising your imagination and i think
if i don't actually
get that then i start you know kind of
losing a sense of my kind of that
surreal
place that you can go to in your dreams
and in your mind so
i've tried to find ways that even if
there's nights where i don't like to
sleep still exercising that
creativity in some way would you say
that you are
ruled by by your head or by your heart
they fight all day every day
it's like you know how someone has the
angel and the devil on their shoulder
i mean that's me but just with hearing
here at all times because
i think both of them that can get you
into trouble i think the
um you know the kind of the
thoughtlessness that you can have when
you're driven just by how you feel
because i think our feelings change
really i mean my feelings change really
drastically all the time because every
experience we have at every second
changes the way that you perceive your
life
are you are you would you say that you
are uh becoming more emotional or less
emotional as you grow older
it depends if you ask like dudes i've
broken up with they'll say
less but i think more
[Laughter]
i would say i would say that there's a
there's a kind of a stigma of
coldness for like a woman who actually
really moves on
but i um i just think you know i've gone
through a lot of kind of
trauma of loss in the last couple years
i had a house fire in malibu where
i lost my house i went through a divorce
recently my grandma was super close with
i lost
and again like in a way i didn't spend
too much time crying over and it wasn't
because i was cold or
trying to avoid feeling something but it
was just because
it wasn't going to change it and i try
to just continue to be
active in what i can control otherwise
you kind of just start feeling like
you're trapped and it can get you know i
understand people that
feel overwhelmed by life's experiences
and what it throws at it's not easy
um but if you can create these kind of
tools that you use and
you know mine isn't crying like to kind
of shed that mind is moving forward and
that's the way i always kind of say i
like heal through movement i heal
through
traveling and and meeting new people as
you lose one person another person comes
into your life
but that i mean that experience having
having a fire
of having a fire and your house burning
down if you
if you could save one item from that
fire what would that be
my elvis shrine i had a shrine to elvis
that i said good night to him every
single night so my favorite movie
i know i'm really weird are you sure you
want to have me on this show
i my favorite movie is called blue
hawaii
and it's an elvis presley movie and his
girlfriend in the movies
name is miley so i i watched the movie
over and over again to the point where
the tape actually ended up getting a
hole burned in it at the part where he
says
i love you miley and i'd watch it on
repeat every day
and so every night i would say i love
you too elvis and i had this like
amazing i had this little mini
motorcycle and i had an elvis clock i
had i had a full
if he was here he would think i was a
creep and probably
say that i'm restricted from going to
any of his shows because
i'm a super fan
even though you're still a a young
artist you
have so many styles and so many
faces behind you uh if you could erase
one of them
would you which one would that be
um maybe
i don't know maybe the fact that i wrote
like an
autobiography at 11 that seemed like
someone jumped it a little bit
that seemed a little early do you have
like uh this sixth sense that
that can notice when people are kissing
up to you
oh dude i hate that i would so much
rather
someone be like horrible to me and
treat someone that they felt was less
than them
you know really kind because i've gotten
enough people that will do that
and i also just i don't think there's
anything i i don't like anything that's
fake you know i everything that i've
done in my life
even if it doesn't relate to me now has
been genuine even if it's for that one
second
it's genuine at that one second and so
anything that feels
like it's a fraud i really i i can't
even entertain it
so when was the last time you
appreciated someone being horrible to
you
my little sister every day of my life
seriously
it's interesting with the with this
situation that we are in now and and
why we're talking long distance like
this uh madonna said that
covet is the great equalizer do you
agree with that
i don't agree with that i think that
we've seen more divide recently than i i
have in
my lifetime just because we're really
understanding the division
between race and wealth
and that wealth and health can actually
be the same thing and i think that
that's unfathomably wrong
um and that's why our election is so
important so no i do not believe kovit
has been an equalizer in any way
you're your parents had uh
a very different upbringing than you had
mine was yeah my life was definitely
more privileged my dad
uh grew up in the appalachian mountains
of kentucky and my mom
grew up in ashland kentucky you know
they actually went to competing high
schools
so my dad was a was the competition
football player
at his school but my dad you know didn't
my dad did not grow up privileged in any
ways my mom was a little more middle
class but
my dad grew up really poor and he like
lived in a bread truck when he was in
his 20s making music
he um came out to la to sell used cars
you know he he had just a really
different life than mine i think it's
why i'm appreciative and i think it's
why i understand
that divide and you know i'm i'm really
lucky that my dad's had his
feet planted on the ground and could
instill some of those um
in me even though knowing that i'll
never be able to understand first hand
but he he didn't want you to become this
child star that you became right
well he knew that it came with a lot of
heartbreak you know and and
i think he knew that at some point
if you want to make music that's one
thing but if you want to do it on the
level
at which i perform it's a whole other
thing because at the end of it it gets
you get kind of trapped into a business
and actually i've
i've made a nice divide between the two
i i make different types of records two
different kinds of records
one of them i'm an artist and one of
them i'm a part of the music industry
and those are two very different things
you know at some point
it's again all of us have to work for a
living so at some times
it's working and sometimes it's like
purely passion and i've
tried to create a a real idea between
the two because they serve different
purposes ones are for me
and one is for everyone else to love i
was interviewing your sister
and she was on this show and she said
that the most important thing she
learned from you was never to check the
commentaries on the internet
well i'm glad she said that because
she's never told me she's listened to
anything that i've ever said so now i
know that she's faking it
yes uh i know that your godmother is
dolly parton
uh do does she feel that she's free to
give you
advice very much you know one thing i i
hadn't been seeing her that much lately
because i had gotten so busy
right before you know this year before
2020 2019 i was touring a lot and doing
a lot of festivals and
one of the like kind of spank she gave
me was we didn't need a pandemic to keep
us apart you haven't come to see me
anyways and i was like
ouch so she was saying that i hadn't
spent enough time with her so that
that i got she only faxes by the way so
that i got you know like
when someone kind of goes in on you in a
text is one thing
you can kind of just delete it and move
on she will send it in
writing a paper
of paper in what way would you say she's
also a role model
in every way i mean just the the
kindness just
outshines the talent times a trillion
her kindness is just i think is really
what has gotten her to be
loved by all i mean you know something's
wrong with someone if they don't love
dolly parton like you're
you're wondering it's like not loving
kittens or something like it's just
weird
and even if you're not into country
music again she's just
she's she's erased that line of this is
my genre and this is
who loves me i mean everybody even if
you're not a fan of country music loves
dolly parton yeah
before i wrap up here i just have to ask
you how is kate moss
fabulous um large and in charge
good good to hear yeah i have to just
explain that kate moss is her dog
one of one of how many um
i in total about because i got them all
over the place
seven and and kate moss doesn't really
look like kate moss does she
no it's very disappointing for the men
on set when you say that you're bringing
a plus one
and they see the name on the call sheet
and then something totally
separate arrives
miley it's been wonderful talking to you
thank you so much for doing the show and
you too thank you so much
thank you hope you enjoyed the clip
for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you